well i told you yesterday that we would
be looking at this today the
rehabilitation for lack of a better term
of the biden presidency that's happened
over a period of just 26 days is quite
stunning think back to 26 days almost a
month ago gas prices were down a little
bit but not really that much we had just
gotten yet another higher inflation
report
joe biden had had a significant lag time
in terms of major legislative
accomplishments during his presidency
and many were saying
what is the game plan here what is the
justification for voting for democrats
in november what's the justification for
thinking it's even remotely plausible
that joe biden might run for reelection
in november uh in november of 2024 that
is um and you had a relatively strong
strong trump doing rallies surging
searching still with quite a high
favorability rating among republicans
and think about the last 26 days
where we have now seen a significant not
yet explosive but significant very
decided uptick in joe biden's approval
rating if you take a look at the numbers
you see that the approval rating for joe
biden bottomed out right around july 20
july 21 that was kind of the low point
now closing in on about a month ago
and since then it has been a decidedly
positive trend
not so much in terms of the numbers i
mean it's really just been a shift from
37 to 40 but remember that these are
averages among many different polls and
the direction is clearly positive
compared to past presidents you might
remember that 538 has this great tool
where you can compare
uh joe biden's current approval rating
to those of past presidents at this
point in time i believe were
574 days into joe biden's presidency
um
and it was below every single president
dating all the way back to truman it's
now not quite so bad if you compare to
prior presidents joe biden's uptick is
now putting himself within striking
distance of where donald trump was at
this point in his presidency
if you look at um
bill clinton uh with just a couple more
points uh biden would now have an
equivalent approval rating to that of
bill clinton at this point in his
presidency you look at reagan basically
the same that gap where reagan was more
popular at this point in his presidency
has essentially been eliminated and
biden has almost caught up there uh
roughly equal to jimmy carter and uh now
above harry truman harry truman uh
very low approval rating at this point
in his presidency only 33 and joe biden
above that so what is the reason for
this change well it's a combination of
things it's some good news for joe biden
and really just humiliating bad news for
republicans and for donald trump if you
look at the biden side the positive side
inflation reduction act
pact act
a jobs report with more than twice the
number of new jobs created versus the
expectation a wage report wages up half
of a percent in july
inflation report inflation
year-over-year coming down for the
12-month period ending on july 31st and
yes although admittedly controversial
among progressives the strike that
successfully killed al-qaeda terrorist
ayman al-zawahiri no due process of
concern to many down on the left we will
talk about that on the thursday show
but as far as presidential
accomplishments tend to go
taking out
a known terrorist on the most wanted
list
generally speaking is considered an
accomplishment and i know everybody will
get mad and everybody emails me and says
david how can you call that an
accomplishment how could you gloat about
that it might not even be legal i'm with
you i'm with you but as far as
presidential accomplishments are
concerned it certainly counts so joe
biden doing significant uh uh
significantly much to help himself and
then also you look at what's happening
on the republican side donald trump now
under criminal investigation for
violating the espionage act among a
number of other different federal
statutes his home mar-a-lago having a
search warrant served tons of stuff
taken
we learned yesterday that trump's former
personal lawyer rudy giuliani is now
under criminal investigation in georgia
we learned yesterday that donald trump's
trump organization cfo alan weisselberg
is getting ready to take a guilty plea
uh it's it's all very very bad on the
trump side so all of a sudden you have
the midterms not looking so bad with
democrats now not by much but slightly
favored to take the senate democrats
still likely to lose the house but maybe
by not very much
and at least a reinvigorated democratic
electorate now what will actually happen
in november and what is the viability of
trump and or biden to run in 2024 still
unclear
but a dramatic dramatic turnaround from
where things were
certainly 60 days ago oh and gas prices
i forgot to mention gas prices also uh
yesterday or today
ending something like a 65 consecutive
day decline all of those things are good
as far as the presidency is concerned
and yeah i mean listen
it's a reasonable thing to make the case
that actually
higher gas prices in a sense are good
long term because they encourage people
to abandon gasoline-powered vehicles
you're 100 correct if that's your view
but the narrative is the very high gas
prices are a negative indicator for the
economy gas prices coming down are a
good thing and so we have to analyze
these things not so much in the full
depth that you and i might
but in terms of how it is perceived as
far as a presidency goes and a very good
26 days for joe biden will it continue
we don't know but we will follow it